es ya un denominador común varios
grandes ríos de europa tienen caudales
mínimos de agua esto en medio de una
nueva ola de calor que se expande por el
continente españa italia francia y
alemania son algunos de los países más
afectados
tenemos temperaturas que alcanzan los 38
grados centígrados o incluso los 40 en
el suroeste pero también en el este de
francia esto empeora la sequía actual
sin lluvia en todo el país sé que la
lectura de la precipitación sobre piel
en españa los embalses están al 40 4% de
su capacidad lo que ha llevado a varias
regiones a restringir el consumo de agua
la peor parte se la llevan los
agricultores que han visto cómo se
reduce su capacidad de cultivo maíces se
ha reducido casi el 50 o 60 por ciento
debido a no haber agua ni pantanos ni
ríos ni
embalsamiento si no hay agua para regar
este maíz hemos pasado de cuatro
estaciones pues nos hemos quedado con
dos lo cual la planta esto no lo quiere
la agricultura no lo quiere este aumento
de temperatura se está cambiando también
los usos agrarios del suelo en italia la
toscana siempre fue una región conocida
por el cultivo de olivos muy sensibles a
las heladas invernales
ahora el exceso de calor merma la
cosecha y amplía hacia el norte más frío
el ámbito geográfico en que se planta el
olivo con este nuevo situación y clima
estas nuevas condiciones climáticas
provocan un desplazamiento del cultivo
del olivo hacia otras latitudes se
cuestiona otras señales que por tropo
esta es otra señal que lamentablemente
confirma la existencia de un cambio
climático en curso que es imposible
ignorar el nombre de r nórdico noche se
espera que esta nueva ola de calor
pierda fuerza a partir del miércoles o
jueves el problema apuntan los expertos
es que seguirá sin llover y las olas de
calor en europa serán cada vez más
fuertes y frecuentes